[Musique]
lors du matin et on est venu au cégep de
saint-jean-sur-richelieu pour discuter
avec des jeunes de 18 19 20 25 ans des
enjeux qui les préoccupent dans le cadre
de cette campagne électorale fédérale
condé d'entre vous allez voter pour la
première fois
et combien en s'avouant les façons
d'aller voter
ça me fait ni chaud ni froid qu'il y
avait des élections peut même que je
pense que pour lui ça va peut-être très
juste qu'on a besoin de ça en ce moment
moi je comprends pas pourquoi il a fait
ça c'est la question du passeport
l'accident s'attache très bons sujets
abordés lors des élections du côté de la
vaccination on dirait que j'ai un petit
peu mal à l'aise avec le fait que
diviser la population s'est enveloppé
d'une société ou c comme montrer vos
papilles avec toutes les dépenses que le
gouvernement a fait son retard bac 5 et
l'association pour gérer la pandémie il
va tout cet argent le c'est nous qui
vont le payer aux fleurs avec les
baisses d'impôts est ce que ça vous
inquiète la berd va vraiment quelque
chose d'abstrait réponse aux gens ce
qu'ils falloir remettre pis
il va falloir qu'ils prennent l'argent
ailleurs fac oui c'est moins d'argent ne
restait menaçante et éducation hôpitaux
cirfa que c'est pas ce qui me préoccupe
[Musique]
d'autres gens qui veulent me parler d'un
jeu qui est pris aux tripes c'est ce que
mon environnement c'est ce qui me
préoccupe le plus malheureusement la
majorité des des partitions pouvoir
depuis les dernières années est il faut
pas assez de choses pour aider au niveau
des deux leaders est toute la question
de l'environnement revient souvent à
queue au moi personnellement c'est
surtout ça qui va jouer à savoir qui
veut faire poids par rapport à ce que ça
commence déjà été présentées depuis
quelques décennies fait que tu est ce
comme les je pense que le npd son camp
plus pour l'environnement puisque c'est
quelque chose qui m'a fait vraiment et
personnellement
[Musique]
la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre à l'entente
de faerie pas ça va influencer peut-être
mon choix de vos élections à savoir
qu'est ce qui se passe avec peut-être
viser les travailleurs étrangers parce
que dans le domaine le ton et moi je
tends l'aménagement paysager puis on
ferme à la guerre au manque de
main-d'oeuvre présentement comme angers
angers nîmes et cannes est effective et
je me demande ce que je me réoriente je
continue ce que je suis parce qu'il
permet ce fait cinq ans que je suis sûr
c'est que j'ai un salaire qui rentrait
compétitivité à comparer deux quand je
rentrais sur la marche le marché du
travail en sont pas faciles moi je suis
étudiant belge et erreurs techniques de
gestion agricole
c'est ce qui me tombe otages pense à ce
que je me disais sur gap tragédie
travailleurs étrangers parce que c'est
impossible que j'aurai assez d'employés
pourraient
faire tout qu'est-ce que gilles bornais
de façon dont l'entreprise
au coût de la vie mobilier les logements
s qui en a qui ont des choses à dire là
dessus j'ai des amis qu en salle en
appartement ils doivent payer tellement
plus cher qu'avant juste acheté une
maison plus tard sans vue veux même pas
y penser comment ça vous coûte échange
de vraiment d'été pour ce tacle oui ça
fait un petit peu parfait la marche
immobiliers